[Music]
unfortunately the connection was lost
let me remind you that about an hour ago
in the metropolitan district an
emergency occurred an unidentified
flying object fell onto residential
buildings
the number of victims of this tragedy
has yet to be accounted for
right now representatives of the
atlantic alliance are in correspondence
with moscow hoping to also gain access
to the crash site of the object
for now experts are afraid to confirm
the words of eyewitnesses that what is
happening has the hallmarks of an alien
invasion and yet from different
parts of the world we are receiving
information about improving the combat
readiness of the armed forces
at this time the streets surrounding the
crash site of the facility are all
cordoned off
representatives of the defense ministry
have so far refused to comment but
locals report that military
groups have begun to approach the
strange ball combat helicopters are also
monitoring the object
all teams
report radiation levels average
negative
we have contact he's in my sights
i'd say it's time for a welcome speech
greetings
good evening i'm michael polskin
member of the interfacial parliamentary
group
we are representing the country uh um
terry of defense uh
uh the sector uh this is uh
lebedev um we
are ready to engage in cooperation with
you first step which
was our assistance in your successful
landing we would like to
assist you in any way we can in short
the planet earth welcomes you don't no
sudden movements
302 ready to fire stand down
3 002 standing down
report all details
[Music]
you